for us the most important thing
in normal uh
in normal world days when you get like a
message from a teacher or a message from
a parent
tell us like it's exactly what i i was
waiting for it's exactly what i wanted
for my student or my kid
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders let's talk
about a bootstrapped startup that
started with a real mission from a real
story meet michael pellet the ceo and
founder of sing it
as a child diagnosed with dyslexia
michael pellet ceo and founder of singet
struggled to learn english at school his
father told him that he learned english
using the beatles and pink floyd songs
and that is how the idea was born
learning english through the power of
music
during his military service in the ofec
unit of the air force felid and his
partner benny rossner cto and founder
decided to turn the idea into reality in
2020 they began developing the syngit
app and created a unique platform that
allows each student to learn english in
the best and most effective way by
listening to students favorite songs
the
integration of of art music lyrics
and language education english
to teach people english and help people
learn english through music i think it's
a you know it's one of those things that
are that are so innovative today you
know in the 2020s where we're able to
leverage some interesting technologies
and look at the way we experience the
world that traditionally was low-tech
textbooks and see how we can actually
help people absorb information better
understand it better experience it in a
more fun and exciting way obviously you
have a personal experience and a
personal
story that has led you to this
understanding and so i'm really excited
to have you here michael and in these 20
minutes unfold a little bit about your
own journey as well as seeing its
strategy and and what the company is
doing so thank you so much for being
here
yeah again thank you so much for letting
me letting me talk here and you know and
spread my uh
spread my story and and explain a bit
about edutech so it's a
you know the the
the less the well-known of uh
you know the the tech here they take
intervals
so
like the story of my company starts in
uh something in that area but uh
for honesty it's
started
a lot earlier like
the the company itself
uh came from the idea that
even when i was like in third grade as a
dyslexic uh
exactly kid that comes with a family of
uh dyslexic kids
and
and a dad
what does dyslexia really mean just to
just to make sure that we're aligned
here yeah so dyslexia uh
really
so it really depends on the age and you
get uh you know you you
people realize they are dyslectic and
normally it's really impacting have a
real impact so dyslexia have like a
couple of branches so
most of my family and me are dyslexic
with a
really high attention to dysgraphia
and so and what is that really it's
really impacts how you read how you
process
information how you can
write
and how can people understand your
writing and your reading so it can make
you know uh a twelve normally
a a 12 12 year old kid or a 14 year old
kid with dyslexia it's the first time
they're gonna read fluently when normal
kids uh read
fluency from their from from first grade
like six since they're six or five
and so
and you know for all just to
distill it for a second michael so when
you're saying when you're talking about
the differences and what it means to to
grow up with dyslexia because at the end
what you're touching on with your
companies is understanding that people
learn in different ways people
experience and absorb information in
different ways and you're accommodating
to that
when just share with me the experience
of
learning something learning a new
language learning a new writing or
reading what is that like for you
as a kid compared to
you know somebody else in the class that
may not be dyslexic
so uh so for me it was like my my
regular life like i i i get born to to
you know to to see the other
the other student that sits
next to me you know when he learned for
a test like one hour before the test and
i learned for the test for like you know
three weeks and we get the same grade or
even he get the higher grade and
i knew i i learned harder than him i
knew that i
i work harder than him
i learned more time than him but he
processes the information a lot more a
lot faster because i had a difficult
time to read and when i want to process
what i have in my mind into writing
a lot of things sleep in the middle and
and that's one of the things that sexy
you know really get get the best of you
even if you try your best
and
so i really had the you know the fir
to be
fortunate enough
to be raised in a wealthy family so
since i was like in kindergarten
i worked with a lot of private teachers
and
that helped me
in way in new ways to process
information
processes that help dyslectics and and
really showcase how they can
process information in a better way and
those private teachers show me that yes
i can do math better than you know 99 of
the of the population in the
population but
right and so if we're working now when i
want to when i want to read and i want
to process information and not numbers i
have to do it in special ways and you
know most of most families don't really
have uh
those kind of you know budgets to to
invest in their kids and you know to
just sit right sit them down for eight
hours with private teachers every day
and that's that's something that really
uh
hurt me to see and even as a
even as a
third grade student i noticed that
something is really weird in there
and you know in the um
in the in the education in every school
because everybody learn in one way and
only one strict way even the know of all
people
um process information in the same way
so right
and
so since the third grade uh i noticed
that then i i knew that uh when i would
grow up i want to do something in that
area something that will help students
with dyslexia something that will help
students you know and
work in a different environment they are
used to
fantastic and so if we're looking now at
what you're doing with seeing it and and
obviously it's tying back to to your
personal story and you're and what
you're describing here is the is the
fact that you know the way that you're
experiencing learning and is different
it's special and and you had the fortune
of of having you know accommodations
that allowed you to continue into and to
keep up with everybody else that we're
learning in the traditional
sense
and
you're looking for ways in which
technology can integrate in order to
level the playing field and allow for
people with dyslexia to learn in their
traditional way and not in the
traditional way of people without
dyslexia so tell me about the formation
of singit how how did that come about so
i was in a
a program of white smiling of the white
spanish institute for a gifted kids in
computer science
and you know we got to the end of the
last year of the
of the project you need to to
publish your final
you know your final
your final project is have to be
something web-based
and
everybody
pretty much do the same thing they build
like a semi-control strike
under a
computer science lab or something in
that nature
but i really wanted to take it one step
step ahead and i always remember my
father who was dyslexic
in 19 in the 1960s so
people didn't know what is dyslexic like
they just called him you know maybe
stupid maybe just that does much good
but he can do nothing
and he always explained to me
you know he
worked in the in the u.s like a lot and
he always explained to me and never
learned my english in class like my
english teacher couldn't teach me
nothing and my whole english is
dedicated from for bob dylan and john
and john lennon
and and
yeah and i thought it's amazing like and
he really explained to me he used to
listen to his like mixtapes that he made
from from his radio and and you know he
sat down with an oxford dictionary and
just this is how we learn english so so
i found it fascinating i really started
there you know searching how music helps
you know dyslexic and normal students as
well
and you see how many research should say
says
that music helps you in all sorts of
ways to study and learn better
and
so amazing i took that idea i started to
develop and you know the worst
uh application that i ever made
but
you know it was the mvp of what
now is sing it so i created you know an
mvp with android studio you know as a as
a normal a student in computer science
and
and then
you know most of the kids there you know
publish their final project and you know
finish with the project
but with my project it kind of took his
own
took a life of his own when a lot of
people
came and reached to me tell me it's
amazing project we have to see it in
classes and it was always on my mind and
so
i keep
i kept running the idea you know but i
have to find like
more people to help me and develop
and so
after that you know i joined the army
and i went to uh offic
it's a like a computer it's the computer
unit in
the iaf
in the israeli air force
and then there i found my commander his
name is benny rosner and you know
i found him like an an amazing web
developer and never saw someone that you
know can develop so fast i explained him
the idea and he found it fascinating so
suddenly i found myself like with my
commando
as my partner in in the company and
we've started non-stop developing of the
product
and we finally got it to a place that
that we could run to schools and tell
them look we we find another way for for
your teachers to teach english and for
your students to interact with the
language
after school hours and during school
hours in a different way that is really
interesting and
and we started spreading the word
uh so but but it was like our our side
project like
we have we had so much passion for the
project but you know before i was like
benny was a
you know
his army was his life you know he signed
years in the army
and then i needed to you know to make a
living so so i was wearing the fintech
work in western barcode like uh
i i helped a lot of companies go to to
ipos and fix in that nature
and then suddenly because we kept
working all night on singing because we
had so much passion for this project and
we saw like what what happens to kids
when they using it
so you know
me and him alone started to to write to
the minister of education suddenly you
know the mafmar of english started
writing us back really guide us how to
get an approval for
a the minister education to put you know
the
the product
and schools directly and and working
with the government
and suddenly we find ourselves
with a real approval from the education
company to to put the the product in
schools
so you know both of us like quit
everything
to everything we had and then started
the project and started the company as
soon as as possible we started spreading
the
the product in schools
and making kids work with it starting
start starting to get an understanding
of how the students work
with the product and how teachers work
with the product and what we can give
for both of them to create an
an amazing experience you know
because for us the easiest way to you
know to make sing it was to just publish
it in in the app store and play store
and let everybody just
just play with the product
and
then you know download it or you know
pay for a small subscription
the hardest way we could
do the product and make it work was
with the government and with schools
but it was so important for us and it's
our
ideology
that
schools need to kind of need to change
the way of learning need to bring kids
in alternative ways of learning so so we
took the hard
and you know the hard way
and we believe that
some days will
it will
be very beneficial for the company and
we believe that a lot of kids
really enjoy the product and more than
believe we got an amazing statistics
about students that use the application
after school hours and not only after
school hours
but uh but
without any teacher guidance they just
entered up there to to our application
listen to their favorite songs and learn
english through that so so for us it's
amazing
so so what is the product walk me
through the actual you know
surround itself to
to two different parts like the first
part is the student side
like the student side look exactly like
spotify
the kids have five million songs
well-known songs and that they can
choose from
every um
when he chooses a song that is in his
liking let's say let's go with i don't
know watermelon sugar high like yeah for
me it's some it's it's a song that a lot
of kids really like
in our application
i press on it to get an instant uh
you get the
lynx lyric sync synchronization of the
song so he knows exactly where
the
the singer is in the song and can listen
to what the singer says
and if the kid and the student that
doesn't recognize a word or doesn't
understand the word he can just
personally the music will stop it will
get an instant translation if it's a
noun a verb about using a sentence and
and what is the word itself like what is
it saying
and so
then
so that's one part and
at the moment you press on a word
we remember the student press on that
word that specific port
and every time you will enter to another
song that have the same specific word
we're gonna still mark it because we
want the student to
look at it again listen to the to the
word again
and
see the translation again and we really
you know
indicates how important is repetition
and audible repetition audible is the
base of every
uh learning curve so
we really mimic that then and michael do
do you use
youtube or spotify yes ideas
yes so you know when youtube like offers
you
a video after you finish your first
video because because youtube wants you
to keep
using youtube because he wanted to keep
processing uh videos
so we found it we found it really
interesting so we mimic the same
algorithm it's one of the most the
common algorithms
and how but how does the learning
actually take place
more than the repetition in audible we
see the translation
and so we recommend
songs with the most lyrics the kid
didn't recognize
and uh
and we offered him songs in his liking
with the most words he didn't recognize
and
well still yeah
so and and how does the engagement work
how do you know
what words did he recognize and what
words he didn't recognize
you will enter a song after you burst on
a word or a couple of words
and we will pop up a mini quiz that will
check if you uh
really learn the vocabulary that you
pressed on the moment you will answer
the right
uh answer
in the quiz we will remove the word
from the from your dictionary of words
he didn't recognize and by that we know
that he learned the word because he he
did the correct answer
so we
mimic repetition in audible we make the
student come back to the application
because we give them give him his
favorite songs just like spotify but we
make sure he learns
by
by uh by him just pressing a word it
doesn't recognize and you know kids a
lot of people told us so what happens if
a kid doesn't uh you know press a word
so ninety-five percent of our users
at least press on five or six different
words in a in one song
so it showcases that the students does
want to to study you just need to give
him you know the right way and the right
user experience to make him study
and
and how many students how many students
have so we get 60 000 is worth the
application so for school year
800 schools so
so for a first-year product only in
israel wow it was pretty big and we hope
for even bigger next year
and much bigger spread of the
application
and you know the the most important
thing
for us for me and benny because because
we didn't raise funds
funds
right now you know we still like
you know it's a real start-up with like
13 employees but we still you know find
ourselves like booster boost robbing so
um
so for us the most important wow
uh
thing
in normal uh
in normal world days when you get like a
message from a teacher or a message from
a parent
tell us like it's exactly what i i was
waiting for it's exactly what i wanted
for my student or my kid
uh it's so different
and you know sometimes like i get uh
sometimes i get like real emotional
messages from some from dyslexic
uh students that
maybe like you know they heard about my
story but they use the aptly get so
connected to the app and finally like it
really helps him you know to stay on
track with his class even with his you
know difficulties
uh it sounds fascinating and michael i
love the the fact that your story is
tying into this and
and the understanding that you can
leverage technology to
to adapt to people's
way of understanding and obviously here
this is not just for dyslexic this is
for
anybody who's learning the language
because this is you know you're
combining entertainment with education
understanding that you know why don't we
take the media that these
students are consuming anyways and
leverage it within the school system
right i mean obviously kid kids are
probably not going to go and learn
english on their own after school when
they can do other things but if in the
classroom you can replace the
traditional textbook learning with a
more spotify youtube-like experience
with gamification and get better results
then that's obviously a win-win for
everybody and michael thank you very
very much for for sharing your story
with me i appreciate it this was a lot
of fun and very interesting and i wish
you best of luck with seeing it and stay
safe and stay healthy thank you so much
michael thank you so much for hosting me
[Music]